Today we're going to talk about a problem,
which is really at the heart of robotic vision.
Robots are relatively simple machines. If
we consider the case of an industrial robot,
one that's got six joints, we can control
that by simply specifying six velocities or
speeds. We specify the speed of each of its
motors and the robot can do any kind of action.
A wheeled mobile robot, we control by specifying
simply two velocities; that's the velocity
at which it drives forward and the velocity
at which is turns. So we've got a problem
because the amount of data that comes out
of a camera is of the order of 10's of millions
of pixels per second; 10's of millions of
numbers per second. But we need only two or
six, a very small number, in order to actually
control the robot. It's like trying to drink
out of a fire hose; massive amount of data
coming out of the camera, small amount of
data needed to control the robot. So to get
around this problem we perform a technique
called "Feature Extraction" and what we're
trying to do is find the essence of the image;
the most important information in the image,
we can feed directly to our robot.